[Music]  we're ready  thought I'd woke enough but looks like  I'm still dreaming  [Music]  has everyone left already  anyway futaro hmm go out with me hmm  the student's job is to study for years  I felt like that was all that mattered  they'll all stick together wherever we  are  [Music]  okay okay  Suki's a popular guy I guess then I  guess things are over between us you  sure got yourself involved with a crazy  group of siblings  our time together is never pointless  the way black tease Nino greens Miku  juices and canned coffee that's not  [Music]  it's not a little weird but I'll always  love it exactly the way it is cheers  everyone fine I mean we're all one-fifth  of each other right  swear those four haven't changed since  high school still nothing but trouble